I'm Sean Riley so we're gonna take a
Brook welcome to world's toughest fixes
101 take your notes right there this is
your instructor professor Riley make
sense today we are going behind the
scenes to learn how this professional
rigger uses his experience to get in on
some serious action and how he takes us
his students and audience with it right
here in the pressure dome itself as this
relatively small 10-inch gash but it's
this that makes it a five million dollar
fix I'm passionate about getting
something done I'm passionate about the
science behind it and I want to explain
that to the audience I really want when
Riley shows up on a fix he's walking on
to someone else's jobsite trying to do
his job and there's at the same time and
shooting world's toughest fixes is not
exactly the world's easiest job they
work 24 hours split shift crews over 12
hours
those people come on they'll have a half
an hour overlap so that those people at
the end of 12 hours spend a half an hour
to explain to the next crew what they
did and they'll work for two weeks
non-stop 24 hours a day and in that kind
of schedule fortunately there's only one
of our crew
so you work really hard it's not easy
sure to do I'd say we probably shoot a
ratio of about 60 or 70 to 1 so for
every minute of TV that you see we're
shooting about an hour we come home from
issues with 7080 hours back out on the
runway but we're gonna try to use our
eye our infinite infrared imager that'll
let them get off the plane get off the
ground here and Clara Clara and Clara's
playing Flair's plane to be catastrophe
contestant a catastrophic
and just I like snot I want to see you
walk the walk you watch the show
yeah I'm not walking enough for you the
show yeah yes flow before they'll trust
him to be a good teammate these guys
have to put him through the ringer
what's up brother wow it's almost coffee
time stop having fun I'm sorry I don't
know what we're doing but Riley has a
few tricks up his sleeve to prove his
mettle I may have got a little bit on
the HUP to hook the other time I learned
a lot by being with these crews but I
start out with a pretty fair wide base
of knowledge when the height of the
hanger was in question Riley had the
right tool for the job I am a fan of
lasers I could walk in and pick up my
laser and go Boop the building is
exactly this tall to within a millimeter
good job thanks man now that he's proven
he can hang with the team Riley and his
crew get unprecedented access to one of
the most unique environments in the
world we are in the belly of the beast
I'm fixing a pun Boeing 767 an airplane
we're taking it apart cutting in half
replacing a piece and then ravine all
back together and it's gonna fly the
next day with people on it and fly the
next day after that with people on it
the next day after that so you have to
wrap your head around the stakes
involved or going on
no doubt everybody here would put their
family on the plane first flight oh yeah
no problem at all
wanna take us up to 35,000 feet
professor Riley gets right in the action
and make sure to keep his class
interesting if you come up with a
fracture in the vessel anywhere along
the wall or near the dome it's instantly
gonna depressurize like that might want
to be involved but I also want to be
sharing that involvement line that I'm
experiencing with with the audience and
people would come along for the ride
now that pressure system fails well
would love to inspire people to
understand the world around them a
little bit more and to feel empowered to
try to get it fixed the plane is back in
one piece
everybody's laughing we're packing up
the stuff ready to go home I'm packed up
the planes going somewhere oh geez going
somewhere and I'm going somewhere on to
the next fix
you